digamos que tengo una función fx y
permítanme graficar una f de x
arbitraria digamos que este es mi eje de
las 10 este es mi eje de las x ajá y qué
puede que fx luzca algo así y lo que
busco es aproximarme a fx con un
polinomio de taylor centrado en x igual
aa
digamos este es el eje de las equis este
el eje de la sie lo que quiero es que el
polinomio de taylor centrado en a se
aproxime a la función y ustedes han
visto cómo funciona esto verdad el
polinomio de taylor se hace para que
todas las derivadas hasta cierto 2 hasta
cierto grado sean iguales al de nuestra
función original verdad esto por
supuesto evaluado en a así que el
polinomio evaluado en a también debe ser
el el igual a la función evalúan así que
nuestro polinomio digamos que lo
llamamos pd x ya veces a lo mejor le
pondrán un subíndice n verdad que indica
que la aproximación de qué grado estamos
en qué grado estamos aproximando también
le podemos poner una que significa el
punto en donde está centrado ok mejor lo
escribo de esta forma
se trata de un polinomio de décimo grado
centrado en a y que lucirá más o menos
algo así efe de a más f prima evaluada
en a por x menos a por x menos a más
efe mi prima evaluada en a por x menos a
al cuadrado entre 2 factoriales o 22
factorial y 2 es lo mismo de hecho aquí
podríamos poner 1 factorial verdad y el
siguiente término va a ser la tercera
derivada de f evaluada en a por x menos
al cubo entre 3 factorial y ustedes creo
que ya saben a dónde va esto verdad así
que si nos seguimos hasta el enésimo
término que será la enésima derivada de
f evaluada en a por x menos a a la n
entre en el factor ya
muy bien y es el polinomio es el
polinomio centrado en el polinomio de
taylor de enésimo grado y es sin duda
efe de a es igual a el polinomio
evaluado en la verdad y puedes
comprobarlo ya que todos los demás
tienen un x menos a verdad que si loeb a
la evaluamos en la se cancela así que
pda es igual a fedea y más o menos el
polinomio luce como algo así ver así
digamos
digamos déjenme ver si me sale espero
sea más o menos preciso lo haré lo mejor
posible
ok más o menos y lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo después de todo este repaso
es que si yo tengo una aproximación
polinomio de esta función mientras más
términos tenga es decir mientras más
alto sea el grado del polinomio mejor
ajusta a la curva fuera de a pero lo que
quiero hacer realmente es que piensen
que tan bueno es este ajuste a medida
que nos vamos alejando del punto a así
que voy a definir una función llamada
residuo oa veces también en los libros
se le llama la función error y bueno
sólo para que seamos consistentes con
con toda la anotación de varios libros
lo voy a algunas personas lo llaman el
residuo de orden n centrado en a de x ok
o quizás también lo veas como la función
error pero yo prefiero evitarlo porque
esto parece como el valor esperado de la
probabilidad así que quizás algunas
veces véase esto pero bueno también
llevará sus subíndices en ella verdad
así que esto lo definimos simplemente
como la función dada por la diferencia
de nuestra fx con el polinomio ok
entonces esto realmente va a ser déjenme
cambiar de colores
fx menos pd x donde p de x es nuestro
polinomio de grado n centrado en a así
que por ejemplo si alguien fuera a
preguntarte que te pregunté que cómo
como visualizas esto en realidad de lo
que están hablando es bueno si tú
evalúas este error o este residuo en b
en realidad a que sí a que es igual o
como como puedes pensar esto bueno si ve
anda por acá en realidad
lo que te está preguntando es esta
diferencia es decir este tamaño lo que
nos están preguntando es cuánto mide
este error esta distancia de aquí ok por
supuesto la distancia en a debido a que
la función vale lo mismo en que en el
polinomio pues la distancia es cero así
que déjame escribirlo aquí mismo porque
es una propiedad bastante interesante
que nos va a ayudar a acotar
eventualmente el error así que el error
evaluado en a ya ya no voy a poner los
subíndices a lo largo del vídeo ya
estamos pensando que el polinomio de
grado n que estamos entrando en a así
que el error en a va a ser igual a efe a
menos
pd a donde otra vez ya no le voy a poner
subíndice en ella ya estamos poniendo
todo eso que es un polinomio de grado n
y está centrado en así que como estas
dos son iguales esto va a ser igual a
cero y ya veremos aquí que justamente
coincide la curva en ese punto verdad
ahora pensemos en la derivada de la
función error
evaluada en la
esto simplemente será la derivada de f
evaluada en a menos la derivada de p
también evaluado en a
también evaluado en ahora como dijimos
que el el orden era mayor que 1 entonces
sabemos que las derivadas coinciden son
iguales en así que de hecho puedes
derivar todo lo demás evaluamos en na y
se cancelan los términos que le queden
algún x menos a la verdad
así que cuando evalúas estás derivadas
de tu polinomio na
simplemente nos va a quedar f prima de
la verdad lo cual tiene bastante sentido
por ser una buena aproximación
así que si derivamos efe de a se cancela
después aquí sólo nos queda
efe primaria y en los siguientes
términos pues tendremos algo del estilo
x menos a alguna potencia así que cuando
evaluamos en a todos esos términos
desaparecen el primero ya desaparece al
derivar y por lo tanto sólo nos queda f
prima de a ok entonces ya hemos visto
eso antes dejen de escribirlo porque de
esta forma pep prima de a es igual a f
prima de a muy bien entonces el cuando
evaluamos el error o la derivada del
error en a simplemente nos queda cero
por esta propiedad general aquí esto
esto es cierto para toda n hasta el
término enésimo verdad ya habíamos visto
esto
pd efe de prima de a es igual a efe
prima de a
de hecho esta propiedad se sigue hasta
la enésima derivada evaluada en a que la
enésima derivada de p evalúa de nada es
igual a la enésima derivada de f
evaluada en a
muy bien entonces ahora vamos a ver qué
pasa con la función error la enésima
derivada de la función error evaluada en
a pues simplemente va a ser la enésima
derivada de f evaluada en a menos la
enésima derivada de p evaluada y como
son iguales como ya habíamos visto que
son iguales entonces este esto va a ser
igual a cero esta es una propiedad
bastante interesante pero también va a
ser útil cuando tratemos de acotar este
esta función error y ese es el punto
central de por qué estoy haciendo todo
esto y que lo veremos probablemente en
el próximo vídeo vamos a tratar de tener
una estimación de qué tan buena es la
aproximación cuando cuando tenemos esta
aproximación polinomiales ahora vamos a
ver qué pasa cuando tomamos una derivada
mayor digamos que tomamos la enésima
derivada de la función error
y de hecho si queremos ver la enésima n
undécima derivada de e
simplemente vamos a evaluarlo en algún
punto bueno esto va a ser igual a la n 1
encima derivada de f evaluada en a menos
la n más un décima derivada de p también
es perdón había dicho que en x verdad
entonces ponemos en x
no estamos evaluando ahorita na sino en
equis ok entonces
dejen de esto esto sale de la expresión
que subraya entonces
la enésima derivada de la enésima
derivada de efe - la n más una enzima
derivada de p evaluada en x ahorita le
puse los subíndices pero bueno en
adelante quizás no lo haga así que quien
es la enésima derivada de p si es un
polinomio de grado n ok por ejemplo
piensa que tienes la segunda derivada de
ya iguala x que es un polinomio de
primer grado y estamos tomando la
segunda derivada obtendremos que es 0
verdad si por ejemplo tienes igual la x
cuadrada es un polinomio de grado 2 y si
tomamos la tercera derivada entonces
vamos a tener que es 0 en general si
tienes la enésima derivada de un
polinomio de grado n puedes tú mismo
probar que en realidad te va a dar 0 y
espero haga un poquito de sentido para
ti esto entonces esto que es la enésima
derivada del polinomio de grado n pues
simplemente va a ser cero así que la n
undécima derivada de nuestra función
error evaluada en cualquier punto x
simplemente será la enésima derivada de
f evaluada en ese punto y vamos a
continuar en el próximo vídeo tratando
de ver cómo cómo podemos acotar esto si
podemos acotar esta expresión de la del
error digamos se supone que somos
capaces de acotar esta magnitud es decir
si podemos encontrar un valor m para el
cual sea más grande que el valor
absoluto del error de la enésima
derivada del error y podamos hacer un
poquito de cálculo para poder integrarlo
integrarlo unas varias veces y ver si
podemos regresar a la función original
no sabemos bien cómo encontrar esta cota
pero bueno eso lo haremos en el próximo
vídeo